ils sont venus dire leur ras-le-bol face
à une islamophobie qui est juste de plus
en plus décomplexée à l'initiative de
plusieurs associations une centaine de
personnes se sont donné rendez vous
place de l'hôtel de ville de lyon
leur objectif demander aux autorités de
faire cesser les agressions à caractère
islamophobe et aujourd'hui on a un
climat de haine
un climat d'islamophobie qui leur est
insupportable on se prend au lieu de
culte on brûle des lieux de culte on
attaque des mosquées on attaque des
personnes attaquent des familles en
attaque des commerçants ça rappelle des
demis ombre savent à peine d'une période
très sombre de l'histoire de france
aujourd'hui les musulmans risquent
d'être les jeux d'hier et nous ont dit
basta pour que les hommes politiques
arrêtent faut que les faiseurs d'opinion
arrête cette surenchère diabolique qui
consiste à montrer du doigt une
catégorie de la population
sur le mois d'août seuls deux mosquées
ont été incendiées à lyon et dans sa
banlieue
la mosquée omar à bron et celle des
salam à perrache à chaque fois les
sinistres ont été rapidement maîtrisé et
l'hypothèse criminelle privilégiée d
enquête pour dégradations volontaires
par incendie ont été ouverte et confiée
à la sûreté départementale de lyon
aujourd'hui la communauté musulmane
appelle le maire de lyon ainsi que le
préfet à faire tout leur possible pour
identifier les auteurs de ces incendies
nous exigeons que tous ont mis en oeuvre
pour que ces auteurs des différents
crimes
soit soit maîtrisé et soient déférés
devant la justice et nous exigeons
également que dit stop au buisson est
connu comme un déni message du film est
déjà arrêté de donner la parole à ces
fascistes avaient été donnés de parole à
ces gens qui sont pleins de haine qui
vient dé parler la haine dans les médias
qui veulent opposer une france et une
autre dans le viseur des manifestants
justement le polémiste eric zemmour ou
l'hebdomadaire valeurs actuelles
responsable selon eux de la montée de
l'islamophobie en france